thank you so this would be on the
theoretical end of the spectrum compared
to what we've heard so far sequence
design problems but let me before I
start with the main topic just mentioned
briefly a paper that just came out in
genome research where we analyzed the
metal ation paper patterns of thousands
of humorous 25 cancer types and
enhancers seem to be the most
differential in terms of the methylation
paper pattern that they show between the
normal in the cancer tissues and this is
pretty uniform across the tissues these
methylation patterns were distinguished
very nicely the primary tumor types
according to organ and source and
specifically regarding metastasis we
found particular enhancers whose
methylation is correlated with the
survival and some of these were new and
were tested experimentally and now to
the main show so we are talking about
inscription regulation both on the our
DNA and the RNA level so TFS regulate
gene expression and RNA binding protein
regulate post conscription run
regulation and the way to measure these
is on the TF level is using protein
binding microarrays or what we heard
from Nadal their synthetic enhancers
that one inserts into living animal and
in both cases the water if we want to
probe systematically there the set of
possible targets we need to design a set
of double-stranded sequences that
together cover all gamers and this was
actually done in both cases similarly
when measuring protein RNA binding one
RNA compute for example covers all
possible nightmares multiple times in
unstructured RNA probes namely those
that don't form secondary structures and
again to probe this to evaluate this
setup requires coverage of all RNA camer
so so here of course the problem is
single-stranded now the tool that we are
using our the brewing sequences so just
a reminder of the definition the brewing
sequence of order K over alphabet Sigma
is a sequence where each camera appears
exactly once and this is of course the
most compact or presentation and the
length will be size of the alphabet to
the power of K and it's a very
well-established field especially now
that it's also become highly popular in
next generation sequence analysis and
one of the way to generate such
sequences is using linear feedback shift
registers now such a design was actually
used for the original PBM but it is
there are some improvement that one can
do over the basic use of the brewing
sequence and this is the fact that we
are talking about in the DNA case we are
talking about the double-stranded DNA so
whenever we design the blue sequins to
cover or k-mers we are in fact also
covering all these k-mers using the
other strengths so any candidate we
generate on the blue sequins gives us
for free the green segment in the
reverse complement so one would think
that a better design would be a more
compact design will be possible and
similarly in the RNA case
we want to avoid the structure down a
probes because they are not useful to us
and we would like to create a subset
that will be more efficient so the first
challenge is how to cover all DNA came
as in double-stranded probe so we'll use
the reverse complementarity to save and
let's define a sick sequence to be
reverse complementary the blowing if it
covers all cameras either in the
original sequence or its reverse
complement namely each came either is
contained in K or its reverse complement
is contained in our goal now the new
goal is to generate a minimum lengths
reverse complementary the bruin sequence
and the algorithm that we developed is
actually an extension or generalization
of the Euler tour which is used to
generate the classical de bruin sequence
or so what we do is we in the Euler tour
algorithm one continuously moves along
the path looking always for a new edge
out from the current node and what we'll
do is to build both the sequence and its
reverse complement at the same time so
while traversing an edge we mark both is
that edge and its reverse complement
edge so here is the tying example we
start from this node and here is their
reverse complement and we move to the
next and then we move to the next etc so
if we can fulfill this process then we
have actually at the end of the day we
will have two cycles one reverse
complement to each other and each them
will be half the size of the total
sequence and
we'll provide us a solution and in fact
the running time of this is optimal so
this works like a charm for odd k
because one could prove that the
algorithm works under three condition
first of all the graph must be strongly
connected then every vertex must be
balanced same in degrees out degree and
in addition so these are the conditions
from the classical Euler tour and we
have an additional condition that has to
do with the reverse complement
apparently the complementarity that
there should be a pairing of edges into
reverse complementary perks and the
problem starts when we are looking at
the case of K even and then they will
have palindromic edges so whenever we
pass we use these edges in the green
path it's already used so we cannot
reuse it in the red complimentary pass
so this is the this is the problem and
the simple solution is just to add cycle
so for example here is one palindromic
edge and here it's reverse complement
and we add a cycle to our graph
containing these two / in roaming edge
and the edges that will connect them
together so we look at all the cyclic
shifts so here we take care of two
palindromic edges and the result of our
process is that we'll have both pairing
so these two edges are it's a palindrome
so it's a reverse complement of itself
same for here and these two edges in the
past the the cyclic shift will also be
reverse complement so we preserve the
degree constraints because we added
cycles
and we preserve the pairing condition
and of course strongly connectivity is
remaining from the original problem so
we satisfy the condition of the CRM and
now we can apply the simple RC the oiler
to algorithm and solve the problem on it
okay so we already said we preserve
connectivity and balance and we can show
it's a simple Emma to show that actually
the cyclic shifts are also where fall
into a collection of pairs the cycle was
already there in the graph but now you
sort of doubled it mono I double it in
order to have two edges here so that I
will be able when I move on this edge to
memo to move also on the reverse
complement which is the same edge so I
created a parallel edge here in order to
have the possibility to move to create
these two cycles simultaneously and if I
just added the these edges I will
destroy the balance and therefore I had
the whole cycle now this is actually
boils down to a very simple algorithm we
have meant the graph by the cycles and
then we run the RC Euler tour algorithm
and this takes linear time but it
doesn't guarantee optimality so the
sequence length C will be slightly more
than optimal and in fact we are not show
here but we developed a network flow per
formulation that gives us the optimal
sequence length at time that is the
network flow type complexity so low
polynomial ah we can also show a simple
lower bound for the length of the
sequence for older k this is the the
optimal case where a case although in
case even we have a lower bound that it
depends on the number of poly drums and
so the interesting case are just for K
even so we plot them here here you see
they just using the original the blowing
sequence algorithm this is the lower
bounded T the theorem gives this is the
linear time algorithm by adding the
cycles and this is the results of the
optimal algorithm for network flow and
you see that it the big the difference
begins to show at its size 10 the
difference is is tiny so in terms of
practical reasons one might as well use
their the linear algorithm and indeed we
have a saving factor of approaching tool
so we need half as many sequences as the
original problem and now over a year on
we'll do the rest solution to the second
challenges that is to cover all cameras
in unstructured RNA probes and this was
done to go with a professor burger from
MIT so first I'll give a formal
definition of the problem and the
problem is defined based on three
parameters one is decay the value that
you want to cover L is the length of the
probe on the microwave and p is the
number of times we want each came out to
appear and when we find a P multicam L
coverage as a set of sequences that
together cover all our any k-mers and
each camera pills it can peel exactly or
at least be times different depending on
what we want to cover and the goal is to
find the minimum p multicam L coverage
by a restricted set of L long sequences
so this is the general definition of the
problem and the application that we want
to solve is the case where the
restricted set is the set of unstruck
showed RNA probes so it turns out that
this problem is np-hard and before I go
and show the proof own overview of the
proof i just mentioned that it is an
easy night here what is the mathematical
definition of unstructured ok that's a
good question actually I left the slide
out but we followed a definition that
was given by the developers of the RNA
compete technology and what they did
there they ran Alan a shapes it's one of
the algorithms to predict RNA secondary
structure and what it gives you an
example of representative structures and
for each one of the structure it gives a
free energy estimates as well as a
probability then they look at all of
this structure that I'll below a certain
threshold of free energy and they some
the probabilities if the sum of the
probabilities is higher than half they
consider the probe to be structured
otherwise it is unstructured so this is
the definition that we followed from the
technology front people who develop from
this thing and you want to under that
constraint you on the sauce so I want to
cover all comers and unstructured
sequences I guess I mean here it's the
same sequence but you can predict
different structures for it and I can
think just that you have an Oracle which
returns whether or not a sequence of
structure yeah so but that's okay yeah
that's what we apply that's what we
assume here yeah I mean we have this
script that gives us a banner achieve a
binary value 0 0 1 yeah so that fits the
formal definition of the general problem
so first so i just want to mention that
the it is an easy problem when we allow
all and long sequences and then we can
just take the bruin sequence and cut it
into pieces Oh in the case well l equals
k and then each sequence is a camera so
we would like to have all sequences now
you might have already sensed a flavor
of this problem which is similar to the
well-known set cover problem and here we
are going to reduce from a variant of
the set cover problem which is
mmmm seat cover so each set can contain
its most M elements and the goal is to
find the smallest subset s prime of
these M sets that together cover all the
elements and Arizona straighten of the
problems that we have the universe in
this case of ten elements and you want
to find the subset of this set together
cover all elements in this case there is
only one solution because each set
contains a unique element this is just
an illustration and the analog is going
to be that each element is going to be a
k-mer and each sequence is going to be a
set that contains these gamers but these
problems and are not equivalent and the
reduction is not immediate and the main
difference relies in the membership of
elements that is independent in the case
of the set cover problem so if I have
element eii I can have element ej
without any consideration the membership
is independent but on the other end when
I ever came or ACG you for example I am
guaranteed to have the camer cgu and
some other nucleotide so there is a
dependency between the cameras that are
members of the same sequence just that
comes just from the overlap of k-mers so
we need to use some trick to solve this
to resolve this dependency near I give
overview of the reduction so first we
take each element and we map it to some
something we called an a representation
so we choose K to be the ceiling of log
of the number of elements the base of
two so we can represent each element by
a binary vector then we can turn each
element by its number to a binary
representation and then just convert the
bits to a nu so we have this a
representation now we want to put all
those representation together but we
don't concatenate them as they are we
prepared each representation by k GS and
append by cases and in that way we can
break the dependency so we need the set
of sequences to cover all of the
original elements and we will have other
sequences that will be able to cover all
the G
nck murs that we have in the set so we
need to augment this set with additional
sequences which I am NOT going to
mention here be killed because it's a
technical detail of the reduction but
basically this is the set of sequences
that corresponds to each of the original
sets in the input to the set cover
problem then we can just give the set of
sequences and find the KML coverage over
the alphabet ACG and luckily the running
time of the reduction is polynomial so
it is safe to say that the KML coverage
problem is np-hard so we got something
bad from from being similar to the set
cover problem maybe we can benefit from
that as well and there is a well-known
and greedy algorithm that is a
guaranteed approximation ratio for the
set cover problem and that the
approximation ratio is logarithmic it's
in fact the harmonics am so we can use
it in our case as well we can apply the
greedy algorithm and get this ratio of
the harmonic some which is the sum from
1 to the size of the maximum set in our
input and in our case all of the
sequences contain the same number of
gamers so it's a mnemonic sum up to l
minus k plus 1 and armaan exam is
bounded by the natural log plus 1 so
this is going to be the first algorithm
we first have to find all along
unstructured RNA sequences and once we
have those we can apply the greedy set
cover algorithm where the elements are
going to be all are any k-mers and the
sets are the unstructured sequences
unfortunately the running time of either
of these steps is at least four to the l
and l is 35 or greater in most of the
application that we sign during
production so this becomes an
impractical algorithm so this leads us
to developing a heuristic algorithm
which actually does not I disappointedly
has no guarantees but works well in
practice and the key point is what that
we are going to find these random walks
in the broom graphs that together cover
all of the edges and these random walks
have to represent unstructured sequences
and in addition we have to
up with some backtracking strategy
because it might be that we find the
path but it is structured and we find
another path its structure then we have
to have a few attempts till we find the
unstructured path so these are the key
points that we need to take care of in
our algorithm so this is the second
algorithm that I'm going to present and
we start with generating at the growing
graph of all the K minus 1 so this gives
us that each edge represents a gamer and
then we can also add copies in case we
want them multiplicity that is greater
than one for each gamer then we iterate
as long as there are still edges in the
graph because it means that they are
camer that we didn't cover and we try to
find an unstructured a longer path if we
find one we can output and remove the
edges from the graph and if we did not
find we can keep trying till some number
of attempts it can be set by the user
and if we did not find we can we try to
look for a path that is shorter by one
nucleotide and we keep on going and we
might be shortening the past a lot if
it's very difficult to find an
unstructured sequence and if we get to a
length of K minus 1 this means that we
find an empty path which has no meaning
so we just output a random edge from the
current vertex and we move on to looking
for a new path in case we closed a cycle
which can also happen we just output it
and we continue from a new visited
vertex similar to the oil to algorithm
so in the end the running time that we
get is proportional to the number of
probes times the running time of the
secondary structure prediction algorithm
which is usually bounded by at the
length of the sequence else L square
where L is the length of the sequence x
el because this is the number of
extension of shortenings that we might
do for each probe the number of probes
is in the order of fall to the K now the
output of this algorithm is going to be
a set of sequences that together cover
all cameras and each camera pills
exactly p times but it might be that not
all of these sequences are of the same
length l and it might be a requirement
of the technology that all of the lowly
goes on the microwave the same end so we
suggest another heuristic algorithm to
extend all of the oil goes to the same
length and the case that we have we have
shorter oligos other when we closed
cycles or we found the structured
cameras this is this you know simply
avoid cycles by marking all the places
you've been in simply excluding the read
more from stepping to those yeah that's
another possibility but then you might
you might have been left with just a
half that are shorter because you didn't
go into these paths these editors would
be in the graph you will need to cover
them in some way so it might be that you
are left with a short path just to close
this cycle because you didn't want to
cover it and one of the requirements is
to cover all comers so one way or the
other you would need to go over these
edges and include them in some path and
the path might be shorter than ow so
first we just try a random extensions so
we place the short sequence in some
random position in the oligo and the
sign random nucleotides if we succeed we
can output it otherwise if we fail we
suggest that we break the sequences into
two equal sized pieces overlapping so we
don't lose any camera and then we
continue recursively if eventually in
the recursion we go to a size of k then
we have nothing more to do but we output
it they came up with some random
nucleotides so some notes about the
implementation detail so as I have
already noted and we limit the number of
random attempts that we do in the
algorithm you what fraction of lentil
probes are unstructured so I have that
is a adán slide and s 0 for example for
the length of 45 it's that it's less
than ten percent of the probes for land
for 35 it's about twenty percent so
these are the values yeah so so that's
why just using a random the brewing
sequence doesn't work because most of
these will be structured yeah let's go
so we limit the number of random and
tempt otherwise if we do an exhaustive
search it would take for it might take
fall to the L we do that we'd do some
improvement in the rank time in the
extension by doubling the probe length
so we lose the fact go from a factor of
l2 logo and we also can get some
improvement but it is not implemented by
doing the extension in using already
solved subproblems of the secondary
structure prediction algorithms which
usually walk in using dynamic
programming so and go on because I'm
shorting time so now going into the
results and the question was what can we
compare to we don't have an optimal
solution so first we suggest to compared
to a theoretical lower bound which is
only based on the number of Kimmel's
that need to be covered and this is fall
to the K times P divided by the number
of came as we can fit in each sequence
and we also suggest a naive algorithm
which generates random Ollie goes if it
is unstructured Oliver that covers and
structure uncovered cameras we added to
the pool and the other result so we ran
the algorithms for length 30 35 and 40
and for different values of K and first
looking at the incomplete set but
incomplete I mean that some of the oil
goes maybe shorter than L we see that
the ratio compared to the theoretical
lower bound is about 1.1 so not too bad
we are not increasing the size of the
set too much compared to a theoretical
lower bound when we are looking at a
complete set virtual we're all oil goes
out of length L we see that already we
get some ratios between 1.1 and 1.3 now
looking at the knife set that is
generated by the naive algorithm it is
doing much worse it produces the library
that is about four or five times greater
in size than what we produce and I
should also note that as you see
starting from k equals nine we also get
some structure two probes in our pool
and the reason for that is that there
are some self structured k-mers so these
are came as that form structure with
themselves so we have no way to include
them back to include
some structural probes another way to
define the problem would be to exclude
those and then cover all the rest of the
caymans just with unstructured probes
now we also compared the specific design
of the RNA compete technology and which
was the way they did that they took the
brewing sequence generated from linear
feedback shift register and then use
some other Krul's to generate a library
of the properties that they wanted so in
our case we just ran the algorithm with
K equals nine lengths for 35 for the
probes and the multiplicity of 16 and
what we see that the ratio that we get
is one point 07 compared to the
theoretical 01 compared to the library
they used with where the ratio is one
point a 38 so that is a huge reduction
in the number of probes needed to cover
all cameras in unstructured sequences in
addition the number of structured probes
that they included in the set is also a
smaller three times smaller than what
they used and just to add to that in our
design all of the only goes were of the
same length 35 in their design they add
valuable and 35 to 38 it might be that
if we were allowing our algorithm to use
different clamps we can also have
reduced the size of the output of the
result so some future extensions we hope
to generalize to other properties of
required for DNA or RNA probes we know
that it's very it's a very flexible
scheme so if for example we want to
remove some cameras or to exclude them
we can just remove the edge from the
graph and rerun the algorithm and indeed
in Delanie compare technology for
example two cables will exclude it
because they work leaving sites of the
enzyme that was using the protocol we
can also assign different multiplicities
to the different cameras and just rerun
the outdoor thing so to summarize I hope
that in this talk I convinced you that
the brain graphs are very useful for the
purpose of designing libraries of RNA
and DNA probes I think one of the
reasons why they are so useful because
they are much more flexible and indeed
they can produce all possible deployment
sequence and any tea brewing sequence
can be
as a corresponding go alert Oregon drew
Albert in the graph in the de béarn
graph as opposed to linear feedback
shift registers which have a much more
limited number of different sequences it
can generate which is the number of
primitive polynomials of affinity field
and we hope that with this new algorithm
we can design more libraries depending
gun and you can just plug in a
difference property some script that
produces euroval or one and rerun the
algorithm on that so we're thanks to the
labs from which these two walks came
from the first DNA walk was when I was a
PhD with a professor shamir and the
second walk is with professor Bell girl
doing my own going postal and thanks for
your attention so you choose the
socially relevant excellent
and have you tried the same thing and
compared to this guarantee consider ya
know so I didn't go into this direction
I guess choosing a few random points you
would maybe they would collide or
something like that so you would have to
resolve in another ratio in their
algorithm I'm still curious about the
definition of unstructured or the times
at which is computed presumably don't
pre-compute for each portal y el Mar
whether its structure unsure of your
grade no with this part of the algorithm
every time it does an extension it runs
down you do it as you walk across a step
you consider the new Elmer that would be
more traversal yeah it's not pretty
computed for all possible and so what
you are algorithms be applicable to all
these capture probe design
well I think it depends if they need to
cover all cameras on our subset of the
cameras but if they are looking to
include genomic sequences then it's not
as applicable collection of regions in
the genome and I'm trying to design the
set of probes so you know a small set
though yeah so yeah if they can
represent it by a subset of gamers and
then these k-mers our edges in the graph
then you can and run the algorithm and
find paths that cover all of these set
of gamers yeah yeah so theoretically it
can be applied SLCC or algorithm is
random I suppose the results also our
random yeah can you say what about the
variety of serving the results I didn't
check that yeah I mean for the small
numbers just is just an impression I
mean I don't have systematic proof so
that i get about the same numbers
because i think the number also i mean
that's just an impression so I don't
have systematically number so big that
the variance would be small but yeah I
don't have a systematic evaluation of
that verse is one word yeah it is
produced by your honor yeah figure well
its height both speakers again